much of benya's argument about the
supposed connection between bad outcomes
and the free market is based on
conjecture but he does make one attempt
to demonstrate that his argument is not
merely conjectural which I want to take
seriously his very specific Claim about
the pattern of slowed economic growth
over the period he covers his argument
is that free market ideology began to
dominate by the late 1960s to the 1970s
and that as a result economic growth
slowed in each of the Decades that
followed I'll show how his factual claim
does not quite withstand scrutiny in a
podcast interview Pena made do allowance
for the difficulty of explaining why
economic growth slows quote our
understanding of growth he stated is
highly incomplete and we are to some
extent talking about things we don't
fully understand unquote but despite
conceding a limited grasp of the factors
that cause economic growth to slow he
still claims to find a trend that lights
up the road
quote but it is a fact he goes on to say
that average growth declined in every
decade from the 1960s through the Arts
in the United States adjusted for
population and it is a fact that during
that period we saw a fundamental shift
in our approach to managing the economy
unquote
the fundamental shift he refers to is of
course the alleged ever tightening grip
of free market ideology he continues
quote if we think that that approach
promoting free market ideology was
consequential it's not unreasonable at
least to wonder about how it might have
affected that Trend unquote to emphasize
the importance he places on that Trend
let me also quote this from his book
quote the market Revolution went too far
growth slowed in each successive decade
during the half century described in
this book adjusting for population and
inflation unquote notice he emphasizes
that each successive decade suffered a
Slowdown from the previous decade by
adjusting for inflation he means real or
inflation-adjusted growth in gross
domestic product and by adjusting for
population he means growth of real GDP
per capita as mentioned and the best
evidence is that Progressive ideology
not free market ideology has become
increasingly dominant but Pena is also
mistaken about the pattern of slowed
growth which leaves a major flaw in his
core argument here are the numbers
provided in this book on growth of real
GDP per capita which span 10-year
periods and which report to show a
Slowdown in each successive decade with
each of his 10-year periods ending in
the ninth year of each decade let's
start reading those numbers from top to
bottom it's clear that growth slowed
from the 60s to the 70s from 3.13
percent to 2.160 percent
now look at the next step growth slowed
from the 70s to the 80s from 2.160
percent to
2.156 percent
but was this really slowed growth 2.160
to 2.156 Binya had to take these numbers
to three decimal places to get his
desired decline round each of these
figures to two decimal places and you
get 2.16 in each case which comes to a
flat Trend this inspires the old joke
that if you torture numbers long enough
they'll confess to anything and Pena's
been used three decimal point torture
clearly indicates how much the pattern
matters to him even the next step from
the 80s to the 90s from 2.156 percent to
1.98 looks a little suspect a slow down
of less than two tenths of a percentage
point
I put each of these annual numbers on a
spreadsheet grouped them enrolling
10-year periods and found the pattern is
sensitive to which years you choose
while there is a Slowdown from the 60s
to the 70s and from the 90s to the odds
the middle decades show no real pattern
but a relatively flat trend
as one way of illustrating this I'll
show how easy it is to get the reverse
patterns from binyas in the middle
decades by tracking 10-year periods that
differ by only two years from his since
the updated numbers go through 2021 the
most recent year available I worked
backwards from there so each of my
10-year peers ends in the first year of
the following decade I got this as a
result also taken to three decimal
places to stay consistent with benue's
method let's also read these numbers
from top to bottom we see a similar
decline from the 60s to the 70s from
3.070 percent to 2.040 percent but from
the 70s to the 1990s we get a slight
acceleration instead of being used
slight deceleration
2.040 percent in the 70s
2.046 in the 80s and 2.329 in the 90s
the 90s to the Arts show a similar
slowdown from 2.356 percent to
0.926 the odds to the teens do show a
pickup but the 1.488 rate in the teens
is still pretty dismal the point is that
the middle decades deprived Binya of the
linchpin of his argument that growth
slowed in each successive decade over
the period under review he wants us to
believe that the grip of free market
ideology placed a gradual choke hold on
growth now we are forced to believe the
alleged impact was felt only twice
somewhat prematurely from the 60s to the
1970s since by benue's own account free
market ideology was beginning to wield
only beginning to wield destructive
influence in the 70s we then find zero
impact in causing a Slowdown in growth
from the 1970s to 1980s which included
the presidency of free market ideologue
Ronald Reagan and zero impact from the
80s to the 90s instead we had to wait
nearly 30 years until the Yachts for the
impact to be felt a second time
the corrected Trend must send Benya back
to the drawing board to devise some
other attempt at a coherent narrative
given the relative incoherence of his
current narrative his initial disclaimer
still applies quote our understanding of
growth is highly incomplete and we are
to some extent talking about things we
don't fully understand unquote
I could elaborate on a totally different
explanation for the slowdown in growth
since 2000 that I regard as more
plausible having to do with the decline
in the economic freedom into index since
2000 which reveals the declining
influence of the free market but I want
to use the time remaining to make two
more General points
I'm about to quote from a passage in
venue's book that betrays a certain
mindset about the free market he writes
the following about the state of poverty
in the early 1960s quote
about a fifth of the American population
then lived in destitution with little
Prospect of betterment both liberal and
conservative administrations had taken
the view that poverty was best treated
by pursuing broad economic growth but by
the early 1960s Scholars and journalists
were focusing public attention on the
inadequacy of this strategy unquote
so if it's been your rights there was
quote little prospective betterment
among those in poverty we can only
assume that things hadn't been getting
better for quite a while and if the
scholars involved were focusing on
public attention on the inadequacy of
the strategy we must assume this was
based on their scholarly research and we
further assume this scholarly research
lent support to the federal government's
announcement of its war on poverty in
1964. Benya cites no data in this
account but now try a very different
narrative that does cite relevant data
from social scientist Charles Murray
quote in 1949 41 of Americans were below
the poverty line when LBJ announced the
war in poverty in 1964 that proportion
had dropped to 19 percent in just the 15
years between 1949 and 1964 the American
poverty rate had dropped by 22
percentage points what had the
government done to help by the
definition of the 1960s and thereafter
nothing the federal government was
missing in action in the real war
against poverty and yet somehow America
cut poverty by more than half over this
period Well the trend Murray cites as
was well known when Binya wrote his
mistaken account I suggest that this
reveals a certain bias despite binya's
occasional nods to the benefits of the
free market in areas that include such
Trends as the decline in poverty the
decline in the rate of auto accidents
and the increase decrease in injuries in
the workplace the progressive assumption
is that government regulation is
required to fix the problem since the
free market has done not virtually
nothing to fix it these misdependent
part on ignoring the evidence that
trends like these were noticeably
improving before government got involved
it's a short step from there when
considering any bad outcome to regard
the free market as guilty until proven
innocent and government innocent until
proven guilty finally I can't avoid
mentioning mentioning something else in
benue's book that falls into major error
he places great significance on the
trend displayed in this charge the
long-term downtrend in all wages and
salaries as a percentage of gross
domestic products but in constructing
this chart he ignored the advice of his
Source the Bureau of economic analysis
or Bea in two basic ways first the be
tracks Bea tracks not just wages and
salaries but the growing category that
covers benefits including pension and
health benefits benefits that are no
doubt important to Binya as a New York
Times employee second the Bea tracks not
just gross domestic product but net
domestic product net domestic product is
simply gross domestic product minus the
depreciation of capital and the Bea
instruction clearly conveys the point
that use of net domestic product is more
accurate in calculating this kind of
percentage I quote this from the Bea
handbook net domestic product is a
measure of how much of the nation's
output is available for consumption or
for adding to the nation's wealth
unquote
well here has been his chart
through the second quarter of this year
which takes wages and salaries as a
percentage of gross domestic product now
here is the same chart
with the corrections I take from the Bea
labor compensation which includes wages
salaries and benefits as a percentage of
net domestic products notice that
binya's downtrend disappears in this
corrected chart
properly measured it turns out to be a
relatively flat Trend and not as Pena
has written a smaller share of the pie
so I encourage him to go back to the
drawing board on all these issues thanks
[Applause]
thank you uh Gene Epstein
um we've got five minutes of rebuttal uh
do you want to you can use the handheld
mic either way you can sit or stand
we believe in Choice here
[Applause]
so there's a lot there thank you Gene
for your close engagement with my work I
appreciate it um
I didn't mention the uh data that Jane
spent most of his time talking about
because I don't think it's the most
important indicator of the problems in
the American economy it's an interesting
data point it's stylized you can take it
or leave it I think there has been a
downward Trend it is possible to cut the
data in ways that make it a little bit
bumpier a little smoother I concede that
point uh but I don't think it's the most
important Point as I said at the outset
by many measures the American economy
and aggregate has done quite well uh
where we are faltering is in the
distribution of prosperity not in the
creation of prosperity that is our
particular Challenge and that's why that
was not one of the points that I
actually made at the beginning of my
talk so you can take that for what it's
worth